Fleischgeschmack ganz ohne Fleisch - das
versprechen zumindest einige Veggie Burger.
Sebastian Lege verrät uns,
was in Veggie Burgern drin steckt und
wie Geschmack, Konsistenz und Optik der
fleischhaltigen Originale nachgebildet werden.
SEBASTIAN: "Heute gibt's lecker Burger zum Feierabend! Was hältst du davon?"
Leckere Burger haben mittlerweile auch
in Deutschland Tradition.
Die Hauptzutat: ein saftiges Patty aus Rindfleisch.
SEBASTIAN: "Genau so soll ein Burger Patty aussehen."
"Schönes Rautenmuster, richtig heiß, kross gegrillt. Lecker!"
Doch mit dem Original haben die Patties auf Leges Grill nichts zu tun.
Was wie Fleisch aussieht, besteht hier aus rein pflanzlichen Zutaten und liegt damit voll im Trend.
Supermärkte und Discounter bieten immer
häufiger sogenannte Veggie Burger an.
Komplett ohne Fleisch, dafür aber
ordentlich teuer.
Lohnt sich der Griff zu den neuen Produkten?
Ihr Versprechen: Trotz pflanzlicher Zutaten sollen die Burger nach Fleisch schmecken.
Sebastian lädt Kalle zum gesundheitlich
unbedenklichen Test.
SEBASTIAN: "Und? Lecker?"
"Noch nicht mal er merkt das!"
Sonst ist Kalle kein Veggie-Fan.
Doch wie schafft es die Industrie,
Fleischgeschmack so gut zu imitieren?
SEBASTIAN: "Ich weiß, wie es funktioniert."
In seiner Werkstatt zeigt Lege im
Kleinen, was industriell im Großen passiert.
SEBASTIAN: "Das ist ja schon ein kleiner Zaubertrick,
aus pflanzlichen Produkten einen originalen Fleischgeschmack zu erzeugen."
Dazu braucht es eine Menge Zutaten.
Als Vorbild hält sich Lege an das
Original aus Rindfleisch.
Dessen Konsistenz will Lege zuerst kopieren.
Locker und gleichzeitig bissfest - beim Rindfleisch sorgt der hohe Proteingehalt für die Struktur.
Rund 20 Gramm Eiweiß stecken in einem Patty.
Die muss Lege jetzt pflanzlich liefern.
SEBASTIAN: "Um eine Textur zu erschaffen, genauso wie Fleisch, braucht man natürlich ein alternatives Protein."
"Also eine Eiweißquelle. Hier haben wir Erbseneiweiß, Weizeneiweiß."
"Die sorgen schon mal für diesen Biss."
"Denn beim Fleisch hat man ja einen gewissen Widerstand im Mund
und den möchte man natürlich pflanzlich genauso erzeugen."
Kann man auch, denn einige Pflanzen wie
Erbsen sind wahre Proteinbomben.
Mithilfe technischer Verfahren kann die Industrie die Eiweiße heute aus den Pflanzen auswaschen.
In Pulverform bilden sie die Basis für den Veggie Burger.
Weiter geht es mit dem Geschmack.
Fleischig herzhaft muss das Patty schmecken.
Auf dem Grill entwickelt es zudem feine Röstaromen. Eigentlich ist das einzigartig.
Doch Lege weiß: Auch einige Gewürze enthalten ähnliche Aromen.
Richtig kombiniert imitieren sie Fleischgeschmack.
SEBASTIAN: "Tomatenpulver, Selleriepulver, Rote Bete Pulver, Zwiebelgranulat, Salz, Knoblauch, Pfeffer."
Doch dann greift Lege zum
Geschmacksverstärker.
SEBASTIAN: "Umami."
Eigentlich heißt so unsere fünfte
Geschmackswahrnehmung, neben den vier:
Süß, sauer, bitter und salzig.
Doch die Industrie kennt auch perfektes Umami-Aroma aus Hefeextrakt.
In Pulverform kommt das in den Veggie Burger.
Für einen leicht blutigen Geschmack nutzt Lege eine spezielle Zutat: Eisentabletten.
Denn auch Fleischsaft enthält Eisen.
SEBASTIAN: "Backe, backe, Rindfleisch Patty."
Fehlen noch Röstaromen.
Was sich beim Grillen von Fleisch von alleine bildet, muss Lege seiner Veggie-Version künstlich mithilfe von
Sojasoße und Raucharoma verleihen.
SEBASTIAN: "Schauen Sie sich das mal an."
"Aus einem grauen Pülverchen wird langsam eine rot-fleischige Masse."
Die Grundlage für den Fleischlos-Burger ist damit fertig.
SEBASTIAN: "Wahnsinn! Das hat schon so eine faserähnliche Struktur wie Rindfleisch."
"Guck mal hier."
Tatsächlich kommt die Version von Sebastian optisch dem Original sehr nahe.
Fehlt noch der typische Hackfleisch-Look.
Eine körnige, raue Oberfläche in saftigem
Rosa, versetzt mit kleinen Fettstückchen.
Zum Verfestigen vakuumiert Sebastian die Burgermasse jetzt und erhitzt sie anschließend im Wasserbad
SEBASTIAN: "Sieht schon ein bisschen aus wie das
Gulasch meiner Mutter am Sonntag."
Eine Reibe verwandelt nun die Gulaschbrocken in Hackfleischimitat.
Rote Bete Pulver sorgt für den typisch rosa Fleisch-Look.
Fehlt noch das Fett!
SEBASTIAN: "Tiefgekühltes Kokosfett! Da bekommen wir diese typischen kleinen Fettpünktchen,
in unser pflanzliches Hackfleisch."
Das Fett sorgt nicht nur für die typische Optik.
Wie beim Original gibt es auch dem Veggie Burger zarten Schmelz.
Zusätzlich verstärkt Fett die Aromen und Gewürze.
SEBASTIAN: "Schon mal kurz in Form bringen."
"Da ist es!"
"Unser veganes Burger Patty. Typ Rindfleisch."
Experiment geglückt! Zumindest optisch kann die Veggie-Version mit dem Original aus Fleisch mithalten.
Aber für Fleischliebhaber zählt vor allem der Geschmack.
Auf dem Marktplatz in Düsseldorf macht der Produktentwickler die entscheidende Kostprobe.
Auf dem Grill: handelsübliche Burger auf Erbsenbasis, genau wie in Sebastians Rezept.
SEBASTIAN: "Das wird heute ein Spaß!"
"Bin echt mal gespannt, ob meine Probe-Esser das gleich raus schmecken, was ich denen hier serviere."
Gebraten und zwischen zwei Brötchenhälften sieht der Veggie Burger aus wie das Original.
Erkennen die Tester den Schwindel?
SEBASTIAN: "Hi! Du bist der...?" - "Sofian."
"Hallo Sofian, ich bin der Sebastian."
"Ich habe gedacht, ich lade heute die Menschen auf dem Karlsplatz mal auf einen Burger ein."
"Magst du Burger gern?" - SOFIAN: "Ja, auf jeden Fall!"
"Na also, dann hau mal rein!"
"Was sagste?" - "Ganz geil!"
Sebastians Verkostung stößt auf reges Interesse.
SEBASTIAN: "Und da musst du mir gleich mal sagen:
Wonach schmeckt das?"
TESTER: "Ich würde da auf Lamm tippen."
SEBASTIAN: "Du würdest auf Lamm tippen."
TESTER: "Pute?"
SOFIAN: "Ich finde es sehr saftig. Ich glaube, dass Schwein mit reingemischt ist."
SEBASTIAN: "Ist kein Berghamster - das kann ich dir schon mal sagen."
"Auch kein Pferdefleisch?" - SEBASTIAN: "Fury war auch nicht dabei.
TESTERIN: "Also kein normales Rindfleisch, Schweinefleisch oder so was,
was man da normalerweise dafür nimmt."
Auf den ersten Biss bezweifelt niemand, dass es sich um Fleisch handelt.
Nur die Sorte - die lässt sich einfach nicht bestimmen
Auf den zweiten Biss werden die Zweifel
größer.
TESTER: "Ist das Getreide?"
SEBASTIAN: "Weiß ich nicht. Oder verrate ich noch nicht!"
SOFIAN: "Ich würde sagen, dass es was
veganes ist. Aufgrund der Konsistenz."
TESTERIN: "Ich würde nicht sagen, dass das Fleisch ist."
SEBASTIAN: "Ja aber Burger sind immer aus Fleisch!"
TESTERIN: "Das ist auf jeden Fall kein Fleisch."
Trotz Fleischgeschmack: Einige Tester
erkennen den Schwindel.
SEBASTIAN: "Leider ist euer Gaumen viel zu gut geschult. Es ist rein pflanzlich."
"Als Alternative cool, oder?"
"Würdest du ihn kaufen?"
TESTER: "Grundsätzlich ja. Wenn ich mal Grillabend mache, sind auch immer Leute dabei,
die vegan essen wollen, und dann würde ich sowas kaufen."
TESTER: "Schade, dass ich keine Tupperdose dabei habe."
Auch wenn sie geschmacklich nicht ganz an Rindfleisch herankommen:
Die vegetarischen Burger konnten bei den
Testessern punkten.
Viele Verbraucher greifen zu
Veggie-Produkten, weil sie die Umwelt
schonen und ihrer Gesundheit etwas Gutes tun wollen.
Aber sind die Alternativen wirklich
gesünder als das Original?
SCHAUTZ: "Bei den veganen oder vegetarischen
Burgern kommt das völlig darauf an,
wie dieses Produkt zusammengesetzt ist."
"Es ist so, dass teilweise sehr sehr viel Salz eingesetzt werden muss,
damit die Produkte überhaupt dem Fleisch ähnlich sind."
"Mehr als in fleischhaltigen Burgern
und natürlich brauche ich oft auch
Zusatzstoffe und Aromen, damit das
Produkt auch wirklich schmeckt wie Fleisch."
Veggie Burger aus Supermarkt
und Discounter sind ausgeklügelte und
hoch verarbeitete Industrieprodukte. Sie
benötigen eine Menge Zutaten, um den
natürlichen Fleischgeschmack zu imitieren.
Doch beim Thema Umwelt ist der Veggie
Burger im Vorteil.
"Natürlich kann man davon ausgehen, wenn nur pflanzliche Inhaltsstoffe benutzt
werden, dass es dann auch nachhaltiger
für die Umwelt besser ist."
"Denn die Produktion von Fleisch und gerade von Rindfleisch benötigt sehr viel Wasser,
erzeugt sehr viel CO2 und da sind die
pflanzlichen Alternativen - relativ egal
wie sie zusammengesetzt sind -
immer besser."
Und das gilt nicht nur für Burger Pattys, sondern auch für eine Reihe
weiterer Fleischersatzprodukte
wie Veggie-Bolognese oder Veggie-Frikadellen.
Für Verbraucher, die ihren Fleischkonsum reduzieren, aber nicht ganz auf den Geschmack verzichten wollen,
ein nützlicher Trick der Industrie!
Was haltet ihr von dem veganen Fleischersatz und welche Veggie-Produkte schmecken euch am besten?
Schreibt es uns in die Kommentare!
Und wo es die besten Lebensmittel gibt
und was wirklich drin steckt, zeigen wir
euch auf unserem Kanal ZDFbesseresser!